switch things up fall is just around the
corner and it's time for our lifestyle
expert sema cohen to share her fall
favorites she's got a little bit of
everything from tips to stay healthy fit
and more
hello las vegas now happy fall everybody
i'm super excited to be back today and
share with you my top full essentials
and must-haves
first up one of my absolute favorites
for the season healthy crunch is on a
mission to innovate your favorite foods
making them better for you
while still being super delicious they
carry a variety of seed butters keto
chia gems rice crispy squares and
granola bars their products are allergen
free great for kids lunches and they are
also lower in sugar peanut-free
gluten-free vegan
and plant-based the keto chia gems are
the world's first and only keto
certified gems it tastes just like
traditional gem without the sugar and
they come in three delicious flavors
those school approved granola bars are
the first to market allergen friendly
low sugar granola bar
loaded with protein fruits and veggies
amazing the new crispy squares provide
one serving of fruits and vegetables and
alhine fiber
again perfect for all kids going back to
school
all healthy crunch products are
available at sprouts nationwide
throughout the us
for more info you can visit them at
healthycrunch.com
all right
true made foods
true made food creates 100 naturally
sweetened no sugar condiments that are
naturally sweetened with veggies and
fruits instead of sugar or artificial
sweeteners
true made foods products are packed full
of whole veggies like carrots and
butternut squash what i love is that
they are also paleo all 30 non-gmo
certified and keto friendly their
mission is to end childhood obesity and
metabolic disorders by eliminating added
sugars and processed food from the
average american diet this is perfect
solution to a to any school lunches and
any family dinner
sadaf is a family-owned company that's
been around for almost 40 years they
take pride in producing chef inspired
kitchen and pantry items that are
wholesome and as close to homemade as
possible they carry unique kitchen and
pantry items that you can find anywhere
else and they also ship nationwide
cozy up this fall season with sadaf
organic tea they come in three delicious
different flavors and you can also add
the organic honeycomb a perfect fall
addition
will be to either cinnamon sticks to any
recipe you can find them at sadhaf.com
one of my absolute favorites tesla farms
thistle farms makes handmade products
such as candles jewelry essentials oil
by women survivors of sex trafficking
prostitution and addiction who deserve a
second chance in life
tesla farms offer their employees a
place to live a stable job and a
lifelong sisterhood support group
every cell benefits the woman survivor
who makes these products they are an
incredible company that truly educates
and empowers young women and mothers